[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE ENSOR: So thank you guys
for stepping out and coming out
to our little talk here.
Our talk is on dynamic
compute options.
We'll introduce ourselves
here in a moment.
So my name is Mike Ensor.
I'm the VP of Delivery for Dev9.
I have been in the industry
for about 24 years.
I'm a very early
adopter of Google.
I was on the original beta
program for a Google App
Engine.
So that's just some
of my background.
I also I am a certified
architect with Google.
I was number 170.
So my little joke is we've got
about 25 certified engineers,
and there's about
2,000 certified.
So we have 1% of the
world's population
of the certified engineers.
So anyway.
I want to introduce Michael.
Michael's going to be starting
off the conversation here.
So if you want.
MICHAEL GUTTERIDGE:
Good morning, everyone.
Like I said, my name
is Michael Gutteridge.
I'm with the Fred Hutchinson
Cancer Research Center.
I've been there
about 15 years now
running HPC at various levels.
Introducing the Fred
Hutchinson, our mission
is the elimination
of cancer and related
diseases as a cause of
human suffering and death.
What's not on the slide
is that about 2015,
our president gave us 10
years to reach this goal.
So that's an ambitious
goal, but we have 300--
over 300-- faculty and
over 3,000 employees
that are all focused
on reaching this goal.
So I feel pretty confident
that we're going to get there.
Our research has expanded
beyond just cancer.
We're starting to
find links to viruses,
the role of the microbiome
in the development
and progression of cancer.
So the research area expands
with every passing day.
I'm part of the
Scientific Computing Team.
We're a small team
of about seven folks.
We're responsible for
supporting our researchers
and their compute needs.
We support almost a full
stack compute hardware,
the software, the
tools, as well as
some high-performance storage.
So we have a smallish
cluster, about 1,200 cores
over 510 systems.
Right now, we're running
about 1.2 petabytes
of data that grows by
24 terabytes every day.
We have some
miscellaneous systems,
large compute nodes we
use for casual prototyping
work and some other
miscellaneous functions that
aren't satisfied by the cluster.
But it's a pretty
diverse environment,
and it's a growing environment.
So the core of our talk is
high performance computing.
What is high
performance computing?
Well, at the Hutch, high
performance computing
is pretty much computational
resource beyond what's
available under your desk.
We scale horizontally, meaning
we use commodity hardware.
We just add more hardware
as we need more capacity.
It's what you might call a
Beowulf, or a shared nothing
style cluster, versus
something like a Blue
Gene, a Cray, or one of
those more exotic machines.
Why do we need it?
Well, we've got about
seven years left
to cure this cancer problem,
so we need a lot of compute.
We're answering and
asking a lot of questions
that require a significant
amount of compute capacity.
So how do we use
HPC at the Hutch?
I've just picked out three
research projects here.
Give you a quick
introduction to what sort
of work they're doing.
The Optides Project
is a collaboration
that identifies new
drugs and therapies
for very treatment resistant
tumors of the head, neck,
throat, and of
the brain as well.
One of their key problems is how
you get drugs across the blood
brain membrane to
deal with brain
cancers and other diseases.
They're a very diverse project.
They work a lot of
proteomics data.
They use a lot of genetics
data, high throughput sequencing
based calls and
alignments, as well as
protein structure and
functional predictions.
Just to give you an idea
of the scale of their work,
they've used 141,000 CPU
hours since the 1st of May.
The Malik Lab is run
by Dr. Hartmut Malik.
He's part of our basic
sciences division.
I've read through his
area of research twice,
and I still don't
entirely understand it.
He's basically looking
at the problems
that can be classified
under genetics
of evolutionary conflict.
Does a lot of de
novo genome assembly.
So new genomes come in, they
try to put them together,
figure out what's
interesting about that,
how they've changed.
Short read mapping, single
nucleotide fault polymorphism
discovery.
They're probably on the
smaller scale of compute
for the center at about 11,000
CPU hours since the 1st of May.
And finally, the GECCO Project.
This is a really large project.
It's been ongoing for a
number of years at the center.
We've got about 40,000
participants in this one.
And this one is basically
aimed at colorectal cancers
and how the environment
affects your risk for getting
a colorectal cancer.
They do a lot of work
with whole genome.
So they do a lot of work
looking for new genotypes
in the existing data sets.
G by E, which is genetic
versus the environment, how
the environment
affects your genome,
and then how that transfers into
your risk of getting a cancer.
Like I said, they're one
of the larger projects.
They've used about 205,000 core
hours since the 1st of May.
So with an institution
this large,
we have a very diverse toolset.
We have a few of the big ones.
Our bioconductor is our meat and
bread and the first class tools
that we maintain.
We're getting more
interest in machine
learning these days as we
move into more clinical data.
And then we've got the old
workhorses, SAMtools, Picard,
things like that that do your
traditional genetic analysis.
We've also got a lot
of custom pipelines
that are being built at the
center where people are trying
to chain together
different tools using
a variety of systems, scripts,
more modern things, air
flow, et cetera, to chain
together various tools
to answer their problems.
We maintain all of these
using a couple of things,
easy build and L mod,
that lets us build
our tools in a
reproducible manner
as well as deliver them
easily to our researchers.
So I discussed the
cluster at the beginning
of the presentation.
We're a big Slurm shop.
We've been using it since
the early 2 dot days.
It's an open source project that
began at the Lawrence Livermore
labs.
It's a very high performance
solution that's used on, well,
as you can see, there are six
of the top 10 supercomputers.
The emphasis on
performance is, well,
it's a key part of
how they developed
and how it's been
very useful for us.
The big system tuning
guide indicates
that they had almost 2 million
tasks on 122,000 compute nodes.
And they started
those in 322 seconds,
which is fairly impressive.
A little bit more down to earth,
30,000 tasks on 15,000 Linux
nodes, and that took 30 seconds.
So we're looking at a very
high performance solution
for managing and distributing
workload to a cluster.
Unfortunately, this
comes with some costs.
To get this kind of performance,
all the nodes in the cluster
must share the
same configuration.
They all have to know
about each other.
You can't have nodes
just joining randomly
throughout the day.
So the cluster has to
have consistent view
of what the rest of
the cluster looks like.
So when you add or
remove nodes, this
is a disruptive task where you
have to reconfigure the cluster
and tell everybody that
there's a new configuration.
We really needed
to keep with Slurm.
Like I said, it's
a key strategy,
key strategic component
of our environment.
We don't want our researchers to
have to learn a new submit job
submission system.
And we wanted them to be able to
just use their existing script,
run with the same command,
same options, things like that
whether they're running on
premises or into the cloud.
MIKE ENSOR: Probably make
a real quick note there.
Slurm, the company that
builds and develops Slurm,
actually did a
partnership with Google,
and did kind of an alpha
release of a dynamic
basically build up a cluster,
do your work, and tear it down.
That still hasn't really
been released yet.
So we'll cover that
a little bit when
we get into more the
technical side of it.
But it is important to note that
the challenges we had really
were the fact that
the configuration has
to be known ahead of time once
you build your infrastructure,
so the cluster can communicate.
There's no cluster
communication amongst new nodes.
MICHAEL GUTTERIDGE: Right.
Yeah.
There are a number of
ways of doing this.
And since our approach, we
didn't want to change anything
for our community, we had to
tie into a lot of resources
that are back on campus.
So that's a big, what
you want to call it,
a big boat anchor on
using the cloud is
that we have to tie into a
lot of on campus resources.
I don't know how many
of you have worked with
or are familiar with Slurm.
It's pretty straightforward.
You've got a controller
in the middle.
You've got your daemons that
run on the individual nodes that
accept work from the controller.
And then you have
a database daemon
that sits in the background and
does all the accounting work
and keeps records about
what jobs were run
and what jobs are running.
There's a few different
commands for interfacing
with the cluster.
They're listed up
there. srun, sback,
scancel are ones that just
allow you to dispatch jobs
to cluster, cancel them, or
see how they're progressing
through the session.
There's two options.
There's a batch option
and an interactive option.
We do have a lot of users
that use a lot of cores
interactively where
they will fire up a job,
and just from a shell
fire off various r tasks
or things like that.
So it's a very, very diverse
workflow throughout the center.
Data management, here,
where's the data?
Well, it's all on campus.
So right now, we come
back to the campus
from our various cloud clusters
to read and write data.
That's a bit of another
anchor and another constraint
on our design as well as
the fact that we're still
using LDAP and the
Kerberos authentication
back to on-campus hosts.
So that's the problem.
We have a tightly coupled
infrastructure dependent
computing environment,
and we want
to take that and
replicate it in the cloud.
So ongoing, cloud is going to
be a big part of our computing
strategy.
We are adopting a cloud
first approach to computing.
It gives us a lot of options,
allows us to scale capacity
on demand, and then scale it
back as circumstances warrant.
We also get new options
and new technologies
easily and quickly rather
than having to wait
to provision things on campus.
We've deployed into
another cloud provider.
I'll leave it to you
to guess which one.
And that's been
moderately successful
given the constraints of
having to use on campus
resources for data access.
But for some work, we're
doing a lot of simulation,
it's been highly
successful in being
able to give people
the capacity they
need to accomplish their goals.
So what we wanted to do
next was expand into GCP.
There's a lot of exciting
things going on there.
There's some new capabilities
and different ways
of managing resources.
So it's fairly exciting to
you to approach Google and see
what we can gain from there.
There's a chance for
us to really diversify
our infrastructure as well as
mitigate any other risk that
might come along with
having a single vendor
solution for our
cloud computing.
But how do we
solve this problem?
We didn't really have
any experience with GCP.
We'd been working with
Amazon for quite some time.
So we want to make
this happen quickly.
We want to use best practices.
We want to have a
solid deployment,
but we don't really know
what they are for Google.
So this is where
we looked to bring
in a partner that had the
experience with Google
to help us get the solution.
We have Dev9, a Google
subject matter expert,
experienced with GCP,
with biology, health care,
and as well as being
Northwest neighbors.
So at this point, I'll turn
over the podium to Mike Ensor.
MIKE ENSOR: All right.
So as Michael had
mentioned, we're
a partner here with Google.
And the nice thing
is I get to mention
this, every time I go
to downtown Seattle,
I drive by their campus.
They have a big sign.
It's a cool campus.
So it's nice that they were
kind of in our backyard.
We do have, our company
does have some health care
and research background as
well for some of the solutions
that we've built. So I'll
just go this real fast.
Who are we?
We're Dev9.
We are a custom software
development company based out
of the Pacific Northwest.
We introduced ourselves
into the cloud world
about six or so years ago.
At that time, we realized
cloud was not a trend,
and we still stand by that.
We think it's going to
stick around for a while.
So that got us into the game.
We started working with
Google about two years ago,
and became a premier partner.
We've got 25 some
certified engineers.
So when coming here to get
introduced to Fred Hutch,
it was actually a really,
really awesome time
to be able to share how
we build infrastructure
and how we build
outer solutions,
and we do it slightly different,
at least we think we do.
And we'll talk about what
that solution is here.
So recap some of what it is that
we were trying to accomplish,
what the problem we
were trying to solve.
We had some unique constraints.
They have 400 some
projects going on,
thousands of researchers around
the world who are actually
using these tools, and we
didn't want to interrupt that.
We didn't want to change
that world for them.
What we wanted to give them is
yet just a different option,
a command line switch
for them to say,
I want to try a
different cluster
or work with a
different cluster.
Some of the unique things
we ended up coming up
with-- so we get to use
all the [? Skylake, ?]
so a lot of the
performance actually
is coming out to
show pretty strong.
So this is what we
started out with.
When we jumped in
here, there was already
an AWS implementation.
Michael and his
team did a great job
at putting that together
to show the two sides.
I originally started seeing the
bottom portion of the diagram
there.
That was the original.
Everything was on premise.
Everything was set up to be
networks, storage arrays,
and whatnot.
That's where all the
data actually lives.
It was expanded into basically
an almost exact copy into AWS
and tied together with a VPN.
Where possible, they dropped
bucket storage for S3
and other types of
technologies there.
So before we get into what
we did for our side of it,
I want to maybe take a small
step back and talk about
what is multi cloud, and
why their approach, like
why we agree with
their approach,
and we consistently
have a lot of clients
who end up approaching both AWS
and GCP, maybe a little Azure
here and there.
Anyway.
So what does is multi cloud?
I think you guys have
heard this multiple times
over the keynote.
I'm not going to go too
deep into that itself.
But I think an interesting
note to see here
is that a research that just
came out, 81% of enterprises
have a multi cloud strategy.
A lot of the time, they say that
other cloud is a private cloud,
but they generally will pick
a private cloud internally
and then expand it out to one.
We're starting to see
that trend change,
and we're starting
to see more cloud
adoption on multiple cloud,
so it's not just one.
And that's where we start
building the tools that we need
in order to be able to
facilitate and interface
into the different clouds.
There are some big benefits.
One, avoiding a vendor lock in.
In a moment, I'll describe that
as also being a negative too.
But avoiding a vendor lock in.
So if you need to move
your applications around
or your computer
around, it's easy to do.
It's nice when there's outages.
If one company's
still able to continue
to do their work when
somebody fat fingers S3,
and it goes down.
It's kind of nice.
Also with multi cloud, you get
to take the best in breed tools
for each of the
different vendors.
I think that's an important
piece to think about.
Vendor lock in's OK, if you're
using it for the right purpose.
So if the tool, and you
know, for example here,
we're going to now enable
the researchers to start
using things like genomics
API, which they technically
didn't really have
an easy access into.
Now that we start having that
relationship with Google,
that data's closer.
They can start using the APIs.
So that's a best in
breed type of tool.
So there are challenges
to doing multi cloud.
And I think this is kind of
a cool little Venn diagram I
drew up here.
Where if when you get into
it, if you really only want
to be completely
agnostic, you end up
with the lowest
common denominator,
meaning that you're
only doing compute.
You're only doing network.
Well, that's about it actually.
So if you want to use any of the
cool features and functionality
that come as a managed provider,
there's none available.
So keep that in mind
when you're thinking
about where your strategies
are with doing multi cloud.
It also does increase
maintenance and governance.
So you have to maintain
multiple different platforms.
And that means it's
also operationally
now you have folks, teams
who have to understand
all the platforms.
That can be a challenge to
a lot of companies as well.
So how do we go
about doing this?
As an industry,
we've built the tools
now to allow us to
have a little bit
of a homogeneous infrastructure.
So we heavily use, we're very
are big fans of HashiCorp
in general as a company.
HashiCorp has a
product called Packer.
What it allows you
to do is it allows
you to define what you want
an image or a virtual machine
to look like, and it will
build that image for you
and either push it into
the cloud you want to,
or build it within
the cloud you want to.
So with that, we can have
the same base level of an AWS
image, we can have
the same one in GCP,
and the same one
on premise, largely
with just the same file,
and you just run it
with different providers.
So that sets us up to create
a base level at that point.
Then on top of that,
we look at what
other binaries and applications
need to be on those machines.
One of those, in this case
here, a lot of the Slurm,
in the cluster a lot
of the Slurm daemons
and those types of
things, applications
have to be on each of
the different machines.
So in that case, we
actually use Chef.
Chef was a great tool for
configuration management.
It allowed us to
write once and use
in multiple different
environments.
We as a company, we expanded
this into with Fred Hutch here,
but as a company, we embrace
infrastructure as code.
It's something that we think
that every company needs to do,
and we basically
automate everything
is kind of my little tagline.
I talk about that way too
much, but it needs to be said.
So when we came in for
Google, and this is very
specific to Google, we wrote--
I'm sure all of you guys, if
you've done stuff on Google,
you immediately know that
it's not the easiest thing
in the world to start with.
You get a whole pile of docs.
You say, now what?
What we did is we wrote
a foundation layer.
We used Terraform.
So what this does, it
allows us to spell out
what a base network and
project structure looks
like within a Google project.
So we can run this.
We set it up real simply.
And it defines that, so we
can move products around,
should we need to, in
a folder structure.
It also sets up
identity management
into a layered structure, so
we can do organization folders
and projects in a hierarchy.
So that foundation gets
run once, sets it up.
Then we have what we
call our services layer.
And this is where we
actually provision, manage
services, such
things as cloud SQL
or other dependent
applications that
are other dependent
managed services that need
to exist within the project.
And then at the last layer,
we actually have an active.
We call it the app layer.
And this is where
you're actively
installing or updating or
changing, deploying, rapidly
changing services within
your infrastructure.
I don't think I had
on the next one.
Nope.
I'll say it anyway.
So one little tip that
we like to try and say it
all over talks is when
you're using infrastructure
as code, if there's
a possibility
to run it in a continuous
integration environment,
definitely do that.
Terraform is another
HashiCorp product.
What it does, it
allows you to be
declarative about what you
want your infrastructure
to look like.
So you can say, this is
the type of machine I want.
I want 200 of them.
And it's just a variable.
You change that, and you run it.
And it allows you to give a
declarative format for what
your infrastructure is.
When you run that with a CI,
it means that you no longer
have an individual who has to
run it off a laptop or even
on a jump box.
You now can have the same
run happen every single time.
It's all the benefit you
get from running a CICD.
A little side effect
of that as well,
Terraform when it builds
your infrastructure,
it creates a state file.
So it knows what
your infrastructure
looks like without having to go
necessarily back to the cloud.
So it can manage itself.
Now along with that,
the benefits are,
if you want to
heavily govern or you
want to govern
your infrastructure
so you're not running
high costs or you
want to make sure
that individuals only
have certain access,
you generally
don't want to give
access to the console
or to G cloud, which is
the command line tool,
so use Terraform to
make all your changes.
It forces you to run through a
pattern when you're using a CI.
It runs your pattern.
That you actually get to
do all of your own code
reviews on your
infrastructure going out.
So you know exactly what your
infrastructure is at any given
time, and you can say, a change
doesn't go through or whatnot.
So talked about our base images.
So in our case here, our
base images, everything
is using Ubuntu.
You guys use some [INAUDIBLE]
No, it's mostly just Ubuntu.
MICHAEL GUTTERIDGE:
It's all Ubuntu.
MIKE ENSOR: Yeah.
So the general idea here is
that you create an image,
and that image is
being pushed up.
I already talked through that.
So here's what the provisioning
looked like for us.
We started out with
a base OS image,
and we used just
really nothing on it.
It was really vanilla.
On top of that, depending on the
different machines themselves,
a lot of them needed to have the
tools that the researchers were
using.
So for example, the SDK for
R, the SAMtool, TensorFlow, et
cetera.
By the way, TensorFlow
is something
that we are currently
looking into just saying,
can we add that
on as being early
add on GPUs into these clusters?
We haven't done that yet,
but it's on the roadmap.
And then at the
very top, you know
if you have all those
Slurm dependencies
and then working with it.
Another thing that was kind of
a challenge that we had to fit
is all of the data, we
said it multiple times,
but all the data
actually was back at HQ.
So researchers throw all their
data, everything comes in,
sits on net storage, and we
use NFS to transfer it out
to the cloud for the
actual compute itself.
So there are some
challenges in that solution
as well just due to latency
that happens with moving
very large amounts of data.
All right.
Actually, I already
covered this,
so I'm going to skip that slide.
All right.
So largely the solution itself
from a technology perspective
wasn't super difficult,
but what it did
is it created a homogeneous
infrastructure between all
of the different providers
that they were working with,
with on-prem with
VMware, AWS, and GCP.
So with that, that
allows operations.
You know I'd
mentioned previously
that operations when you're
doing multiple different clouds
can be a nightmare if you
don't have some level of common
between all of them, so
this gives us that ability.
So here's kind of
the final deck.
I kind of grayed
out the AWS one,
because it's less important now.
But yeah.
We actually run this
cluster over a couple
of different zones,
which is nice.
And we do have some
high availability
built into the clustering of
the application-- or, I'm sorry,
with the Slurm cluster.
And along with that, we have
a lot of attached storage
that ends up working with that.
All the different
systems run over VPN
back into the general networks.
So that way, you have
accessibility to the data
back into HQ.
So ongoing challenges,
we kind of alluded
to the fact that Slurm
itself as a product doesn't
have dynamic clustering or
does not have dynamic scale.
You can't just throw a new
machine into the cluster
and have it auto recognized.
Google did do a product, like I
said, that does help with that,
but it's not public yet.
Or the press release
is, but the code isn't.
So another challenge is, you
know identity management is
another one too that
we are still making
sure we try to stay on top of.
Identity management,
like IM in general, so
what boxes have access to
what data, what researchers
have access to what.
Right now, we have a very, very
generic policy that is maybe
a little too permissive.
But it's a challenge,
because you
have to match that up
with AWS and also what
you're doing with your on prem.
All right.
So at the very
end, so what did we
do by going through
all of this one?
We took the existing solution
that Michael and his team
put together, I would
say we strengthened it
in certain ways.
We brought in a lot of
Dev9's best practices
on how we put together
infrastructure
as code, how we run it.
So we strengthened
that, so we did help out
the AWS and also the on
premise version of the cluster.
But by virtue, we also added
the capabilities for Google.
We were able to now provide
a 50/50 split for Google
and AWS traffic for cloud,
which now means that they
can scale even larger.
The amount of data, as
you saw, 1.2 petabytes
of data, that's a lot of data.
So having that, they now have
the capacity and the capability
of growing that even
larger as they need
and matching the same
amount of compute
that they need with
the demand they have.
They don't have a lot of
resource contention now.
All right, so in
the future, we are
looking at adding in the
capabilities of using genomics
API along with any of the
other machine learning.
The hosted TensorFlow, right
now, a lot of the researchers
are using TensorFlow,
but its the self managed,
and it's non-GPU based,
obviously, no TPUs.
So it's still very
early days for that,
but a lot of the
data they're doing
doesn't necessarily
require it, but it's
something where they want to
start being able to use it.
So we're expanding
the solution to be
able to add those types
of capabilities to it.
Also right now, all the data,
as we mentioned, is on premise,
but also all the compute
is generally in the US.
Fred Hutch has multiple
centers around the world.
And so being able
to actually use
this same solution,
because we've now
created this
infrastructure as code,
we can now create that
same infrastructure
in multiple different
regions around the world
and still have the same
infrastructure for them.
And then the last
thing is, it's a hope,
but we would like to
actually be able to add
in some preemptive
machines as well to this
to help lower the cost.
And a lot of that's going to
come with the synchronization
and the automation that we're
doing for identifying when you
want to build new cluster
or add more to a cluster
and redeploy it.
So we're working on
some of those pieces.
But that will be kind of
a fun next step for us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]